If you draw a vertical line on the same coordinate plan as a function, and the
functions curve should only intersect that line 1 or fewer times. Let's pretend
for a second that this pencil is a vertical line. Now saying that a functions
curve should intersect this vertical line 1 or fewer times, is exactly the same
as saying that each x value should have only 1 y value associated with it.
Remember, just like line A over here, and like this pencil now any vertical line
has an equation that can be written in the form, X equals some number. 4 in the
case of line A right here. This means that every single point along this line
will have the same x coordinate. It also means that if another curve intersects
a vertical line at more than spot, and there's more than one point on that
curve, that has the x coordinate of the vertical line. So even if we drew
something like this. A little bit messy but you get the picture. This blue curve
is not a function. Why is it not a function? Because if we move our pencil to,
actually a tiny different positions along the x axis, this curve would cross to
the pencil in more than one spot. That means that for a given input, a given x
coordinate, you might either end up with one y coordinate, or a different y
coordinate. So vertical lines and other functions that don't pass this test over
here, don't work the same way that the candy machine does. If we had a candy
machine that worked like this, for multiple values of amount of money you put
in, you could end up with different amounts of candy.